hello everyone and welcome to the second
the day of the gold money asian rapid
tournament uh it's magnus claus and
versus anish geary and this is round
seven
and this is uh i think one of the
craziest games that was played uh
i haven't uh checked out most of them
yeah as i only arrived home
now uh but this game it really just
it has it all so now without further ado
let's check it out it's gonna feature
two really really awesome positive video
moments uh so brace yourselves
so magnus with the white pieces opens
with e4
we have e5 by anish knight to f3 that's
not a knight knight to f3 knight to c6
and now bishop to c4 we have knight to
f6
uh so the italian game going for the two
knights defense with d3
and bishop to c5 now so just going for
nice rapid development we have castles
by magnus and the d6 now
uh we have c3 castles and now rook to e1
so all very natural developing moves
we have a6 and now a4 preventing black's
early b5 uh we have bishop back to a7
and now comes knight b to d2 preparing
knight to f1 then you can shift the
knight back into the game via knights to
e3 or g3
and now knight's the g for anish it's a
move that in some lines doesn't really
do anything because rook to e2 is a
perfectly fine position for white you
can just kick away the knight with h3
and all will be well uh but here it's
actually the most played move i i think
it's actually the only played move
in this position because it's a a little
bit different
so here rook to e2 you have to defend
the f2 pawn
and now of course black wants to strike
with f5 but you can do it because your
king is still on g8 so here anish plays
king to h8
and now uh exclusively in this position
h3 has always been played there are very
very
uh some very cool games played in this
exact same position the
one of the more notable ones is where
vessel and apollo defeated hikaru
nakamura
with h3 in luven in 2016 in the
rapids tournament but here magnus goes
for
b4 and now it is already as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game
uh so let's see how anisha deals with
this b4 idea
so he wants to play b5 captures captures
and then have uh
the a file for for his rook because uh
geary is
still hasn't connected his rooks so here
we have
f5 continuing with the plan and now uh
not capturing this would only you know
uh go right into what black wants you
don't want to
develop a black's bishop for free so
bishop back to b3
and now bishop to d7 and only now rook
to a2 so now the two rooks will be
very nice here uh helping out with the
defense of the second rank
queen the e8 now you can even shift the
queen into the attack if
if white allows it and now while you can
play h3 magnus decides to keep this
knight here he doesn't want to further
weaken his position
and he plays e captures on f5 now makes
sense first you make
black waste the tempo and then you
uh allow him to play this developing
bishop captures on f5 so bishop captures
and now knight to f1 we have bishop back
to e6 now countering carlson's strong
bishop here on b3 and
b5 now we have bishop captures and b3
queen captures on b3 and now knight to
e7 and now magnus plays d4 and now
this bishop's range has been somewhat
diminished now it's no longer
hitting that f2 square but it's still
there so if the position opens up
it's going to be an excellent piece and
here uh you have to always uh
consider rook captures and f3 simply
because it opens up the
the the white king's position but here
you don't really have any sort of a
follow-up you have to go back and
there there really is nothing here there
are some people who would play this
but it doesn't really do anything so
instead after d4
we have knight to g6 now the other
knight will come into the attack as well
or maybe via knights to h4 at some point
and now comes
c4 magnus happily continues pushing on
the queen side
and now the queen gains access to the to
the king side as well we have
e4 by anish now attacking this knight
but magnus doesn't care he says okay my
rook is eyeing your queen
so this is never happening so magnus
could
in fact go knight to g5 here put a
double attack on this pawn here
and it would be a nice position for
white black would have to go back to
help out with the defense of the pawn
and then we continue playing
but magnus says nope i'm gonna play
knight the g3 pile up on this pawn this
way because you cannot capture here
uh but anish says yes yes i can because
this is the position from the thumbnail
and that's exactly what i played so uh e
captures on f3 uh he sacrifices the
queen for a piece
for a minor piece and the rook so here
the rook is under attack
so uh he grabs the queen rook captures
an a8 and
now comes queen to d1 uh you could
imagine
something like g captures an f3 but then
you allow rook to e1
check and that's not not fun for for
anyone if if king g2 you can even play
knight to h for with
check and if king h3 you can even play
knight captures on f3 so
that's a really really crazy position
king captures here you can capture on c1
and now you have two rooks a knight and
well once this bishop gets developed and
it is getting developed there is a
double attack here
it's gonna be very very hard for the
white king to play this
so uh instead after rook a captures uh
on e8
queen back to d1 by magnus now guarding
the e1 square
uh from the rook and not knight to
h4 and again what do you play here this
is being threatened
uh and the capturing again on f3 isn't
really the way to go because now you can
just capture with
check and after king g2 just rook to e1
and it's again a really ugly position
for white
to play uh once the queen moves well you
can't really even do anything but if you
wanna if you wanna save the queen
then bishop captures on d4 comes and
it's just a total annihilation here the
rook can come to g1
whenever it wants and it's just too too
ugly to
uh to even look at this but it gets
uglier you know
as you'll see so after knight to h4
magnus plays h3 it is the strongest move
in the position he waited for a while
before playing this but now he does so
he challenges this knight but
giri says nope just f captures on g2
and now again what do you play if you
play uh captures on g4 then you get this
rook the e1
check and now the uh the the knight will
win back the queen so queen captures
knight f3 check
king captures knight captures here with
check and you get this end game
uh where the position the the material
is completely equal but
uh i guess magnus decided that i will
either he can do better
uh or uh maybe he just uh
he just didn't like it who knows so here
magnus played
rook to e2 and rook to e2 is the move
you play
uh when you you found a better move than
the one that i've just shown you however
rook to e2 loses by force and it loses
in such a brilliant way that
well i'm not going to spoil it for you i
feel free to pause the video here and to
win the game for anish
in the most brilliant way possible while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh
if you found this then uh i i mean you
are the the strongest player in your
village
and uh for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight characters on
f2
and it seems like a weird idea because
what happens after rook captures then
if we capture the queen we just get
checkmated but this could not be further
from the truth
so here what would happen is rook
captures an e8 but now we don't capture
the queen we captured the rook that's
the good stuff now the queen is still
attacked
and you can't really do all that much
what do you do here uh if if you don't
do anything if you just move the queen
we can just play knight captures on h3
would check and promote our pawn to a
queen
so here we would have to capture the
knight and it looks great i mean why
wouldn't we play this but now comes the
bishop captures on d4 with
check and again if the king moves we
just promoted the g
pawn to a queen and the bishop defends
the g1 square
now comes queen captures on d4 and it
seems like white accomplished everything
but no uh just g1 check
here we bring a queen into the game and
now you see what's happening so now the
queen
has to be accepted there's no other uh
legal move
so king captures and now comes knight to
f3
with check so king the g to knight
captures on d4
and now this end game is completely
winning for black you're up two pawns
and you are up
uh up the exchange here you have a rook
for a bishop
so this is the incredible uh variation
that was in the position
uh we can even show it once again uh
just knight captures on f2
uh captures now not accepting the queen
but rather captures and now everything
is forced you have to
you have to accept the knight then you
have to accept that the bishop then you
have to accept
the queen and now finally knight f3
check we pick up the queen
incredible stuff but anish said all
right magnus
um if magnus played rook to e2 must mean
that the
knight there's no you know sorcery here
so he played rook captures on e2 and now
magnus played queen captures on e2 and
now he gets some
breeding space but not a lot here we
have knight captures on f2
and now uh magnus has to play king to h2
to just keep surviving here in the
position but
magnus continues fighting actively he
plays bishop to e3 and now
again he allows a niche a brilliant
maneuver
so for the second time uh in this video
feel free to pause
uh and find another brilliant win uh for
for a niche
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those who were able to do it
congratulations
especially if you found the first one
and the second one that means you're
just you know a master of the universe
uh but for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it's
knight to d3 that's the good stuff you
just have to sacrifice everything that's
how this position works that's why
this game is so beautiful and there
there's no good move here
uh the problem is if you accepted the
knight well then it's just a very
straightforward
knight to f3 check and again not much
for you to do here
uh if you play king f2 then we just you
know bring uh
if king f2 we just bring a queen into
the game and that's it the knight cannot
be captured king e2 queen to e1 will be
checkmate
so now obviously we have to uh
after this check we have to capture the
g2 pawn but that doesn't help us we're
just going to play knight to e1 with
check and again another royal fork came
to h1 i'll play knight captures on d3
and again we have
a completely winning end game uh we are
up a whole rook
uh so what you could do after knight to
d3 is maybe not
capture it uh but even that doesn't help
there's a there
there's no good try here if you play
something like knight to e4
then you allow this basic idea of rook
to f1 check and now comes king to h2
and now uh any move here is winning it
doesn't really matter knight to e1
also it looks just brutal you have
knight f3
you have rook to h1 you have uh whatever
you want
if knight to d2 attacking the rogue we
just check the king king the g3
and now even this uh awesome knight to
f5 check
checks the king after the king moves
we're gonna play knight captures on e3
queen captures and now rook to f1 check
or just bring the queen into the game
doesn't really matter
uh if you capture then we bring a queen
into the game with check we're up two
pieces
and white is so close but white never
gets to give
this checkmate so came to g4 again
hoping for a checkmate
but now g1 check and now you have to
trade queens captures captures and
that's it of course now completely uh
win a winning position
so not not even uh you know
there is no playing this so after bishop
to e3
anish had uh knights to d3 but again
it seems he trusted magnus he played
knight captures on h3 but now magnus
gets to hide his king away here on h2
and now uh well the g pawn gets promoted
it doesn't get promoted with with such
effect so here
g1 with check a queen is brought into
the game bishop captures
and now knight to f3 with check and
again
if you capture here then just knight
captures bishop again picks up the queen
so
we can't to do that we have to play king
the h1 this is the only good move for
white
and now knight h captures on g1 with an
attack on the queen
but now magnus gets this queen to e7
move and
this uh ruins uh well sort of geary's
immortal rapid game
uh because now there there's no good way
to to continue the attack for black
gear played rook to g8 but now knights
to f5
and uh well yeah although you can you
can grab some material
there's uh not not much else you can do
a niche play knight captures on d4 but
now uh magnus just played
knights the h6 and here of course there
is nothing more to be done
uh g captures on h6 was played but it
doesn't help if you move the rook if you
move the rook anywhere
let's say rook to a8 you you can even
play knight f7 czech king here and then
this and then it's uh
well and then it's black who might be in
trouble there are all sorts of ideas
here uh so after this g captures an h6
move
uh we which was played the queen to f6
with check
rook the g7 and now queen to f8 check
and here magnus as he's down so much
material
uh he was forced to repeat moves and uh
well
ended this game uh with a draw by
repetition after queen to f6 unmoved 37.
so really really impressive game uh
brilliant position uh
anisha really sacrificing that queen
like a boss and then he had two
two of these great moments where he
could have um yeah
you know it just ended the game knight
captures an f2 and this other one after
knight captures an f2 where
after bishop to e3 and just going for
knight to d3
instead of capturing an h3 but it's uh
who would play knight to d3 this is just
so nice you even grab a pawn
and this is uh i mean knight d3
but yeah luckily for all of you you guys
found both of the solutions so
congratulations on that and hopefully
this
has improved your sunday at least a
little bit
uh so yeah and that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it and as this is the end
of
day two of course keep using hashtag
suggestions so we can check out more of
the games these are the standings after
day two
uh so let's check it out after day two
the leader uh is uh levon arunian uh
ended being lyran with seven points
followed by six and a half uh by uh
wesley so and vladislav
magnus and anish both with six uh
aryon ergasi with five and a half young
shisht of duda with five and then uh
uh players who are uh well you have to
be in the top eight to qualify for the
uh for the real tournament but there's
still one more day so it's of course
possible for
uh most of them to qualify as salim
peter swiddler
and baskaran uh in last place with two
points his game against haifa
was also a very interesting one we're
probably going to cover that one as well
but yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
chingyo-chan
uh be hunter andre sandu david kimura
and nigel holloway for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate
it as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing uh the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day